y dimensionemos la magnitud de este
hecho la muerte del presidente en medio
de esta crisis políticas y sanz también
sanitaria e institucional que significa
para haití el asesinato del presidente
lleva en el mois
buenas tardes santiago y buenas tardes a
los televidentes
la muerte del presidente llega en un
momento donde la situación política
económica del país ya estaba en un caos
y la situación actual del país con la
muerte del presidente nos lleva
directamente al catástrofe a una
tragedia nosotros o sea nadie sabe qué
va a pasar porque en haití hay muchos
grupos armados algunos responden al
poder y otros responden a sectores
opositores es decir hay muchas
condiciones reunidas para que el país
caiga en un cabo total en una guerra
civil o sea ya habían grupos armados
peleando en distintos barrios populares
también el país ha sufrido varias
masacres en distintos barrios populares
el territorio de la capital sobre todo
no está controlado por el gobierno de
haití por tanto en ese vacío
institucional que ya estaba
existente antes de la muerte del
presidente llegamos en una situación
como no sabemos cuál es la salida señor
tumbar la sucesión del poder hay en
haití
es clara ya lo decíamos la constitución
no especifica exactamente cómo debe ser
este proceso entonces qué va a pasar en
el contexto actual que tiene el país
bueno en realidad no es que la
constitución
no está clara sino que hay dos
constituciones hay una condición del
que dice que en caso de ausencia del
presidente debería asumir el el juez de
la corte suprema y hay una constitución
revisada en el año 2012 que dice que
este cargo lo debería asumir el primer
ministro sin embargo esta constitución
revisada de dormir 2012 no tiene
consenso en la clase política fue
rechazada porque decían algunos sectores
políticas no estaba sancionada en los
dos idiomas oficiales del país y además
fue aplicada fue adoptada digamos sobre
el gobierno de michel martelly y el
gobierno anterior al yo ver maurice que
en muchos sectores de la sociedad
consideran que no tenía legitimidad
de esta constitución por tanto hoy el
más cerca del poder sería el primer
ministro actual